how's everyone doing today you doing
good
is my audio okay i'm using these mics
here because you know you got those
little lavalier mics and i've got this
thing this
in the way i actually i did this uh
this is totally unrelated to this talk
but i did a um
i used resnet image classification i
built a bunch of stuff around that uh
just to take random images from the
internet and classify them and i'd go
from axolotls to zucchinis
which i think has a different word here
and i can't remember it is it courgette
yeah courgette see i don't know how to
say it yeah
but yeah so i put my picture in and it
said that i was a fur coat
anyhow
ai's gonna take over the world
so welcome to dungeons dragons and graph
databases
my name is guy royce
i'm a developer advocate at redis there
are three things on this slide that
matter
one of them matters to you
one of them matters to me
and one of the matters to my boss
can you guess what the thing is that
matters to my boss
oh yeah can i get there we go that right
there yeah the redis logo so uh we want
you all to know that redis is more than
just a cache has more than strings you
can do more than getting set
i'm going to show you a little bit of
redis today uh most of my talks about
graph databases and the cypher query
language but my demos will be using
redis graph because there's a graph
database that you can use with redis
there's the thing that i care about
that's that twitter id
i judge my value as a human based on how
many people follow me on twitter
so
please help monetize my narcissism
and thank you
and the thing that you care about
is that github.com guy royce so i've got
a bunch of code that i updated this
morning i'm sure that will end well
and
it's all out there on github all these
slides all the code all the all the
resources are out there on github so if
you want to try this stuff out yourself
that's where you can go
and yes i do have guy.dev as a domain
name
so
if there's any other people out there
named guy that want lastname.guy.dev
i'll be happy to give you a sub domain
and
in addition to being a developer
advocate i'm also a fan of dungeons and
dragons
i've been playing dungeons dragons since
since reagan was president
since the early 80s
um i've been doing it a long time and so
i thought i would show my character
sheet
uh there so there's me
i'm neutral good
so uh
at least i think i am
i guess if i was neutral evil i might
think i was neutral good i don't know
uh but i'm uh a bard was the closest
thing i could come up with for developer
advocate
um
obviously a dwarf
or a wizard one of the other
um
level five armor class of 11.
you might notice if you play a lot of
dnd then my armor class is 11. i'm not
i'm not wearing armor
uh and uh but my dexterity is an eight
so this means like what it is is that as
a developer advocate i've got a plus two
bonus to armor just because i have a
tough hide and that comes from uh being
a public
speaker and so you suffer those slings
and arrows you build a thick thick hide
so
my abilities are over here on the right
of note are the intelligence in the
wisdom of eight
and the charisma of 16
which tells you everything you need to
know about what you're going to get
today which is
all sizzle no steak
but as a d d player and as a person who
runs d d games in general but
particularly as a player
uh i like to maximize my my gaming
potential i want to you know i want to
level up faster
i want to get the gold i want to defeat
the monster this is my problem
how do i
go to the dungeon
and get those the most efficient way
possible i want to find the rooms in the
dungeon that have the things that i care
about
things like monsters
that are of an appropriate experience
level for a challenge rating for me to
defeat but give me the experience i need
to increase my character's level
and has the best treasure
and so you know i'm i'm a developer
advocate i'm a dnd player but i'm also a
developer and so i'm like
i could build a database
and i could put the dungeon in the
database and then i could query the
dungeon query that database and find out
which rooms i should go to first
and i could use the relational database
to do that
right i could have a rooms table with a
big schema and a treasures table and a
monsters table or
i could use a graph database
with nodes and relationships
and i'm guessing i'm assuming but we'll
do a show of hands anyhow just to shame
the few people that this won't be true
of is how many of you have used a
relational database in your career
exactly how many of you have used a
graph database
okay
a few of you
the whole point of this talk is to take
a relational database
compare it against the graph database
show how they can be similar show where
they're different so how do i solve
similar sets of problems
and so
for those of you who didn't raise your
hand about having used the graph
database there's probably a question in
your head
which is what's a graph database
there's probably a small number of you
in here that said oh i thought this was
going to be a talk about graphql
it happens every time i give this talk
actually this is not to talk about
graphql graph ul is a different thing
entirely
but that doesn't mean you should run
away because graph databases are really
really cool
but in order to answer what a graph
database is there's a little bit of what
the heck's a graph
i mean it's not something that my
manager just generates right
to see you know it's not it's not a burn
down chart right
uh what's a graph
well
uh a graph is a set of nodes or vertices
connected by
edges or relationships and as soon as
you see them you're going to recognize
them for what they are they can
represent all sorts of things like a
social graph
would be for example that uh i follow
you on twitter
and then you follow me there's a great
because you just followed me right
[Laughter]
uh and so that's a graph there's a
where the nodes and that follow is the
relationship
or it could be
like a
like a like a genealogical relationship
like a your family tree
is a graph for me it's more of a family
web
but you know your mileage may vary uh
and so a uh
a family tree has like you know there's
a there's a mom and a dad and they get
together and you know do what they do
he said awkwardly
um but so you know there's a
relationship there
the people are the nodes
traffic systems
work this way bus stops are nodes
uh but it can also be things like
objects this 20-sided die is a graph
the points are the vertices
the edges are
well they're the edges
right and so this is
i think worth noting because it shows
that the graph is
it's not bound like we tend to draw our
graphs on pieces of paper and we draw
circles and lines and connecting them
and stuff but they're not bound by two
dimensions or convenience of being put
on a piece of paper they can be
three-dimensional they can be
n-dimensional it doesn't matter
but the whole idea of a graph is an
abstraction around these things that
have
points or nodes and the connections
between them
the simplest of a graph is a null graph
thank you for attending my ted talk
null graph some mathematicians i am told
because i read a wikipedia article
argue as to whether a null graph is a
real graph or not
you know who cares
let's add some nodes
they may be technically correct and as
we all know technically correct is the
best kind of correct
but
this is a graph
it has several nodes
it doesn't have any relationships but
it's still graph
we can put some relationships to those
nodes and now we we get a graph where we
can start kind of talking about it a
little bit
um
this graph has relationships connecting
them it's got pieces that aren't
connected
like we've got node e out here
it's all by its lonesome
it's isolated
and so when a portion your graph is
disconnected from the larger graph or
from the totality of the graph
the full graph it's isolated
and this sub graph here
nodes b and f
best friends forever
are isolated but they're related to each
other they're connected to each other so
they're isolated but they're still they
do have a relationship
and even what you would think of as the
main part of the graph is actually
isolated because it's not connected to
the full graph
if you connect all the nodes
you've got what's called a connected
graph
so this connected graph is
got nodes they're not all fully
connected
because but there's a path so i can get
from node d to node c by way of a and d
or just by way of node a
a fully connected graph i i don't have a
separate fully connected graph picture
here but i have a i've i've grayed out
the rest of the graph and the subgraph
is fully connected and that means that
every node is connected to every node if
you've ever seen one of those network
diagrams the big star it's the big star
and it's you know the every single thing
connects across the chords going across
the big circle
that is a fully connected graph
that that whole n times n minus 1
calculation to get the number of
connections in a network
that's the formula for the number of
connections in a fully connected graph
the graphs i've been showing you here
are undirected
and i i always try and think of another
way to describe this but i always fail
um
node graphs that are undirected do not
have any directionality
which is not a useful definition
but what it means is
there's no arrows
in essence so you can have an extra bit
of information that says this is a
connection from two so in the following
example i gave earlier where if if i
follow you on twitter
that's a directed relationship and then
you following me on twitter is a
directed relationship in the other
direction for the family example that i
used earlier
um there's a natural direction to that
relationship right
you know my mother bore me not the other
way around
and so that has a natural direction um
streets if you were building a
transportation network that has
directionality it's a one-way road right
and so a lot of graphs are directed it's
just a little bit of extra information
we talk about the nodes of a graph
we can describe them with degrees
the degree of a node is how many
relationships it has
if you have a directed graph you can
have out degrees
which is just the number of
relationships that are outbound
and in degrees which is the number of
relationships that are inbound
and i i sort of mentioned this earlier
but there really aren't any rules here
anything can connect to anything
so uh in this particular graph here i
have
nodes a and c connecting
bi-directionally to each other
that follows follows back relationship
uh node a is actually really got a
relationship to itself
you're trolling me
and so they can kind of go wherever and
this has been neatly put out on a
two-dimensional surface so that it looks
good on screen
but you know node b can connect to node
e
without having to draw a big loop around
right it's just it's just the nature of
the relationship
a graph database then
which was our original question
is a uh when you put a date when you put
data on top of this structure
and so the nodes aren't just
these nodes with letters that don't mean
anything they actually become elements
in your data so in this case they become
rooms and they become monsters and they
become treasure and so you give them a
label and so this note is a room this
note is a monster this note is a
treasure
and then you can associate attributes
with those nodes as well other than just
the label of what it is
so if we look here closely we'll see
that uh we have two monsters alice the
elf
uh that has a name she has an idea of
four challenger rating of seven and is
worth 350 experience points if i slay
her
meanwhile we have bob the ogre there's
data associated with that as well
uh fun fact
that's sort of a fun fact my
grandparents were named alice and bob
i've always thought it was really weird
that that's sort of like the stock
personas you always use it for example
when you're doing talks and software and
everything it's like those are my
grandparents names
and
yes my my grandmother was a bit elfin
but no my grandfather was not ogre-like
so he's a very nice old man
um
not only can you put the data on the
nodes
but the relationships have a type
like the room contains a monster or the
room leads to another room
or i follow someone on twitter
and those relationships can have data
associated associated with them beyond
just their type
so you can do the same name value pair
data on those as well
and that gives you a database worthy of
mordor
so
nodes in a graph and in a graph database
they represent items
generally i tend to think that they're
nouns
strictly speaking that doesn't have to
be true but
i find they tend to be nouns
they can have labels
multiple labels and they have attributes
and they can just be by themselves
floating in space
they don't have to have any
relationships
relationships represent a connection and
connect two nodes
they have a type
and they have a direction
and they can also have attributes
but and i think this is important if you
delete a node its relationships go away
so because by definition a relationship
is
has two nodes on either and two points
determine a line you take a point away
you don't have a line anymore
and so they tend to read like sentences
with transitive verbs
the room contains a monster
the room contains a treasure
i suppose you could flip the
directionality of this and have the
monster is contained by a room
but uh my english teacher told me that
the passive voice was to be avoided so
we won't do that
so
that's graph theory in like what 10
minutes
enough enough graph theory let's
actually do something real with this
because i've still got my problem
i still need to find the rooms that i
need to go to to get the gold and to get
the experience so they can level up my
character
and i still have to make a decision on
how i'm going to solve it
spoiler alert it's going to be graph
databases
am i going to use a relational database
or i'm going to use a graph database
and so when we talk to a relational
database
there's a query language we use
anyone know what it is
everyone knows what it is right
the real question is is it pronounced
sql or sql
yes that is the correct answer yes i
pronounce it both ways
so when we talk to a relational database
if we're not using an orm which is
pretty much what everyone always says
nowadays
um you use sql
this is um actually i learned sql in
college back in 1990
something like one or two
and
it's the only programming language i
still use on occasion that i learned
back then
so it's it's it's still there
we all know it it's the language we use
to talk to relational databases
there are a couple languages for talking
to graph databases as well the one we're
going to look at today is cipher
cipher was created by neo4j
who open sourced it
redis used that open source
language spec to build the query
language for redis graph
and uh
you're probably studying that syntax
down there intently and wondering what
is this all about
um
i think cipher is kind of like and we're
going to get into the details here but
the way i it was described to me when i
first saw it when it was introduced to
me was like a cross between
ascii art and a query language
because if you look at that thing after
match there
it's it's ascii art representing the
graph so we'll look at that more closely
these matchers these pattern matchers
they
match they look like what they are like
like this bit here that matches a room
node
a room with a label of node and assigns
it to a variable r
that we can so we can refer to it later
in the query and it's got parentheses on
it
like it's round
it's the way it's the way i drew the
picture up there
the monster same thing
this matches the monster at a monster
node
assigns it to a variable m
and then the relationship here
it's an arrow it's pointing it's showing
the direction of this relationship
and it's got the label on it
which is contains and assigns it to
variable c
and so what these matters do is they'll
go across the entire graph
and wherever there is a room that
contains a monster it will match it
and so if i use the the query i had here
earlier
match
treasure contains a room
room contains a monster
or the room contains the treasure and a
monster is what that query is doing
um
it's going to match all those instances
in the database that have that pattern
so this match
query here would give me all the rooms
in the graph that contain both the
treasure and a monster
and then return them
and so that's that's what these matches
do they match if you've ever done
something with like uh like rust
or elixir where they've got these these
like switch like statements that have
various pattern matchers
it's kind of the same idea but against
the entire graph
so let's go through all the crud
operations
uh with uh with cipher and with sql so
if i want to create a room
for my database of dungeons
if i'm using sql
assuming we have a table already
we just insert into it we know this
the equivalent call in uh
cipher
would be to call create
and then like pass it a node i pass it
the curly brace or not through the
braces the uh the parentheses which says
a node
and i say create me a node and give it a
label of room
and assign it to the variable r so we
can mess with it later in the query
and then after i've created it i call
set and i can just set properties on it
and so one key difference here that you
can see already
is that
in a relational database i've got a
schema right my table has columns
defined ahead of time in graph that's in
in redis graph and in neo4j for that
matter that's not true
i can set any properties i want on there
i'm happening i happen to be setting the
id in the name but you can set anything
you want there
and they can vary from node to node even
though they have the same label
so there's it's schema-less
but that's this index for creating a
node and assigning some properties on it
now that we've created something let's
read it
we all know uh how to read things from
relational databases
select star from users where clue
greater than zero
uh oh zero rows returned
to match uh to query
nodes in a redis graph or in a graph
database with cipher we use the match
command and so that's going to match on
that pattern so this is going to match
everything that's a room it's got a room
label
and then we're going to filter that
through a where clause
where there are id is equal to the id we
care about and we're going to return it
so far it's nothing shockingly difficult
here
what's interesting here i think and one
of the things i kind of like about
cipher is this match where pattern gets
repeated
in this case we're matching
and then we're filtering
and then we're returning
but if we want to update a room
in sql our syntax is different
in graph it's mostly the same
we're going to match where we're going
to find and filter
and then we're going to set the property
so the statue room
is getting an update to a statue hall
and so we match
a room
where the idea is won
we can return it we can set it
and we can delete it
deletion
my favorite command
delete from rooms where id equals one
how many have ever accidentally done
that in production
not not no
[Laughter]
to do the comparable action in cipher
again it's match where but instead of
setting it
instead of returning it we delete it
everyone tracking so far
good
i'm probably going a little too slow
actually
i was like yes yes you are
um there's a variation in this syntax
here uh i've been using this match where
syntax i kind of
drilled it down uh kind of drilled it in
kind of hit you over the head with a
little bit
uh you can also uh
inline all that
so here we're matching a node
all nodes in the graph
where they have a label of room and they
have in curly braces these properties
that match
so this is matching where the id is one
you could put additional properties in
here
and say it's like where common name is
equal to some other thing
and and the syntax actually inside of
those curly braces is exactly the syntax
you would use if you were like defining
an object in javascript not json but
javascript specifically
so the strings go in quotes the numbers
don't that sort of thing
so that's another way you can do that
you can also do that when you're
creating so i created a room and then i
set properties on it
but you can actually create
a node
and provide the properties you want all
in one
motion
so this is creating a room with an id
and a name and you'll note that on this
particular one there's not an r in front
of room
because i don't need to refer to it so i
don't need to assign it to a variable
and so
we already did dungeons
rooms of the dungeon we can create
monsters the same way here i'm using uh
that new syntax to create a monster
and here i'm using uh actually both
syntaxes you can mix and match them
together so i'm creating a treasure
giving it a couple properties and
setting additional properties on it
but it still works the same
so this is our relational database so
far
we've got three tables with rows of them
here's our graph database so far we've
got some nodes floating out there in
space
so far we haven't done anything with a
relational database or with a graph
database that we can't do with a
relational database
let's look at connecting these things
together
let's put a monster in a room
i think nc ndc may have done that
already i'm here on stage so
first thing we've got to do to put a
monster in a room
we have to alter our table
if we're doing a relational database
and then we have to create update the
properties of that table to create those
relationships so we're creating a
one-to-many relationship
you know
a monster has one room each room has
many monsters
done this pattern a million times in
relational databases
how do we do this with graph
like this
you uh
match the room
you match the monster
and then referencing those variables you
can create a relationship between them
so you can create
thing i know about r
contains thing i know about m
there's a temptation
to create
to to in those create statements to want
to try and match
don't do that
if you do that
you'll create new nodes with the same
properties so you've got to match the
things you want to connect together
first you can do this all as one
statement i could say create our colon
room with a bunch of properties contains
m colon monster with a bunch of
properties and i can create it all in
one fell swoop
but if you have existing nodes you have
to find them and reference them first
and then you can
create relationships between them
but this puts
a monster in a room
and because i'm a bit of a completionist
we have a slide for treasure as well
which works exactly the same way
and when you put treasure in the room
it's the same thing except now my text
is golden instead of red
so this is our relational database now
we've got a room it's got a couple of
wonder minis hanging off of it
this is our graph database we've got uh
some isolate all the rooms are isolated
right so we've got a room it contains a
monster or contains a treasure it
contains both but these rooms are
isolate these little subgraphs are
isolated from each other
but it's enough that we can do some
interesting queries
munchkin time
we can find out which rooms have the
most suitable monsters
and which rooms have the most suitable
treasures
so if we wanted to for example farm all
the xp
find the rooms that have the most
the best monster the monsters that are
worth the most experience points
we're doing that in a relational
database we do a classic join select
the id and name of the room
the experience of the monster
from the rooms and the monsters join
them with a simple where there are other
better ways
and order them descending
that will give us a nice ordered list a
priority list of monsters to go and slay
how do we do this this how do we do this
with graph
well we can match all the rooms that
contain monsters
and that will go through the graph and
find every room that contains a monster
if a room contains two monsters you'll
get two results room monster one room
monster two
and then we return those same values the
id the name the experience points
and we can order them the rest of this
actually looks kind of sequel like
honestly
we can order
it by that experience value descending
so the biggest is at the top we go and
we got a priority list
same thing for the gold
again i'm a completionist
so
so far so good right
but so what
i haven't done anything
with a graph database that you can't do
just as easily with a relational
database except maybe it's schema-less
which may or may not be a better thing
depending on whether you like javascript
or typescript
it's fighting words aren't they
well this is where the graph gets
interesting because
what happens when i want to connect the
rooms together
that's a more interesting problem
anyone ever done use cte in sql
was it fun
well maybe for varying values of fun
yeah
um
how do we connect rooms
to rooms in a relational database
by creating a mapping table
you got a many-to-many relationship now
rooms connected rooms and so this is
just a it's actually a table that
represents the graph
because you've got a table of
connections between rooms
and you insert into them so
the first row says room one
uh connects to room one second row says
that room one connects to room two and
then there's a corresponding room two
connects to room one
and so you just create a table that's
got all these
relationships in it saying this node
goes to this node this node goes to this
node
and then when you go to query it well
you need to use cte
how do we connect rooms
in redis
in in a graph database like with like
redis graph how do we connect these
rooms using cipher
it's exactly the same way we put the
monsters in the room it's exactly the
same way we put the treasures in the
room
because the graph database doesn't care
what the nodes are any node can be
related to any node regardless of
whether they are of the same type or
different types this is why like social
media is a great example but it's kind
of a cliched example for graph databases
because
like
you can like a thing
right and that's a relationship guy
liked this post
but i can also like comments on posts
and those are you know you can think of
those as different nodes in a graph
but the relationship's the same type
because it's just
it doesn't care
and so here we just match room one match
room two and create a relationship to
them
so here's our relational database for
this actually rather trivial problem
it's gotten kind of
you can hardly see the dungeon behind it
it's gotten a little complex
and and frankly the blue color i chose
over there is not nearly as good as the
gray and the red and the gold that's
probably the biggest problem with this
uh this this model
so this is our relational database so
far here's our graph so far this is
probably looks familiar right
it looks like what it is
right the graph is got rooms in it and
they are connected in ways that are
intuitive uh this room leads to this
room which leads to another room it kind
of looks like what it is
i actually in some ways feel like this
is object oriented
because i'm thinking about nouns all the
nodes are nouns and like when you're
doing oo programming your your classes
tend to represent things the
instantiated classes your objects are
the nouns of your system
generally
and then the methods are the verbs and
and with graph it's kind of like the
nodes are the nouns
and then the relationships are the verbs
and um
it just feels like
it maps so neatly to my problem domain i
find graph just to be it just sort of
has this intuitive beauty to it
sorry i'm waxing poetic
but now that we have a graph this graph
full of
these rooms and these monsters and these
treasures let's do uh some more
interesting queries
and i'm just going to do the uh the
graph queries this time i'm not going to
do sql equivalents because
because they won't fit on the screen
and this is this is where graph
databases start to shine
you can use this little star right here
say
match n number of leads to relationships
to get to the destination node
so now instead of saying matching a room
that connects to a room or a room that
contains a treasure
i can say match a room that connects to
a room or a room that connects to a room
that connects to a room room that
connects to a room that connects to the
room to connect to your room et cetera
et cetera et cetera
now needless to say
this could be an expensive query
if you've got 20 nodes in your graph
that are all rooms and you say
give me all permutations of paths from
every room to every room
that's a lot of permutations
not going anywhere for a while
um and so this is an expensive query to
run there are ways to optimize it
and some of you may have come to this
have this question growing in your head
saying
so what if my graph is just a circle of
rooms
isn't there an infinite number of
permutations
well yes there are
i will tell you that
uh all the graph databases are aware of
that problem
and they will not like they'll they'll
not circle around multiple times so
you'll get
a subset of that infinity
you can also limit this and say well i
don't want
as far as it can go
i want to go from one
to say three
so this particular query would find
rooms that are one hop away up to three
hops away
so you can limit this
and so this lets you do queries like hey
i'm in a room in the dungeon i want to
find rooms nearby that i might want to
go to
and so to do that i would match a room
with an id of one
leads to
one or two hops away
another room and then i return that
destination room
r i get the id in the name this will
give me a list of all the rooms that are
nearby
now i've got a menu to choose from where
do i want to go
that could be useful if you're dungeon
crawling
i can get more specific
i don't care about the room if it
doesn't have gold in it
same basic query
here i'm matching a room id of one
presumably that's the room i'm in
that leads to one or two tops away
another room but that room has to
contain a treasure
so the match is getting a little more
sophisticated
return the id of the room the name of
the room the value of the treasure
and you know let's go ahead and order it
descending so i know which room has the
most valuable treasure
and let's just get the top one from the
list
so
give me a
give me the most the nearest room to me
that has the most value
give me a room that's up to two rooms
away
and give me the one that has the biggest
treasure in it so this is where i'm
going next
you can query the longest path through
the dungeon
so this query basically solves the
traveling salesman problem
where you can say give me all the rooms
that lead to all the rooms
but it does something interesting here
this is a syntax i haven't shown you yet
you can take
these paths
when you have a multi-hop path you can
capture them
and then you can use them as operands
and functions to ask questions about it
so this here is matching basically all
the paths from room to every room to
every room in the dungeon
and it's assigning all those paths to a
variable p
and then i can return here uh the nodes
that are in that path i can return how
long that path is i could return i don't
in this one but i could return the
relationships in that path
and then i'm ordering them
by length descending so the longest path
is at the top which is going to be the
one that hits every room
and then i limit it to one so i just see
that one
so this lets me be a completionist and
hit every room in the dungeon
i can find the room with the biggest
treasure
so here i'm matching
treasures assigning them to treasure
nodes assigning them to the variable max
and then i'm using i'm using the with to
do a an aggregation
in this case i'm getting the room that
has the i'm getting the value of the
maximum treasure give me the value of
the biggest treasure in the dungeon so
all the treasure nodes
apply a max aggregator give it a little
alias there of max gp
now i've got a variable i can use later
on in my query so i'm going to match all
the rooms that contain treasures
and then i'm going to say where the gold
piece value of the treasure in that room
is equal to the gold piece value of the
biggest treasure
now if there's a tie for first place
you'll get two results back in this
query
and then i just return those values so
this lets me find big treasure
play big games win big prizes
i can combine all this together
to create
something that rivals some of the worst
sql queries that i've ever written
where i'm matching the max treasure and
getting that maximum gold piece value
and then i find all the rooms that
contain treasure where it has that and i
assign that as my destination
and then i get a path from the room that
i'm starting in
to the room i want to stop in and the
room where i start is just hard coded
and the destination is what i just
queried
as that room
and then i can return the nodes and the
length
and then i can order that ascending so
the shortest path bubbles to the top
because there's going to be multiple
paths going to match this
and then i limit it to one so i see that
shortest path so this is the slow
version of the shortest path algorithm
through the graph
this will work
it
i'm going to try and demo it it might
work on my macbook
the better way to do that
is uh this way so this is doing a
similar thing
but we're just calling a function that
is specifically designed to solve this
problem as part of redis graph which
does the shortest path and you just give
it a matcher that says start to stop
and now so this is more performance
a lot a lot more performant
so
that's a lot of queries there's a bit of
a bit of a syntax dump i know um let's
do a demo
are we ready for a demo
do we want to see this this thing is
real and not just a bunch of talk
let's see if i can
okay
yes you're seeing what you need to see
oh my god we're seeing behind the scenes
so i have written i've got uh redis
stack installed on my macbook i think
i've got it running no i don't docker
compose
up
dash d now we don't need to detach it
so i've just got a docker image it's got
redistac redistac is open source redis
with
a bunch of common modules one of them is
redis graph there's search there's json
there's uh time series and bloom and
it's just extensions plugins that make
redis do more things adds new data types
and stuff one of them is a graph
database type in a key
so i've got my i've got that running
and i've got some code here that i've
written we're not going to go too deep
into the code
it's all on github if you want to check
it out but what it does is it generates
a random
dungeon and so i'm just going to go
ahead and run it
like running npm start
and it's done
how's that for a demo
yay um
yeah we're gonna go query this right
so um actually let's write some code to
query it first and then i'll do the the
fancy bubble thing so you can actually
see it graphically so i've got a little
demo.js here i've written and so all
this does is
this is kind of show you a little bit
how the code works but it's not
complicated so i'm just using node redis
i'm using javascript because
because i hate my life
on the plus side it does mean i get to
go home at night and drink so
so i'm just creating a client here i'm
saying if there's an error log it i'm
connecting
i am using a node's new top level await
feature
which came out in i think 14.8 which is
kicks mooches acis it's fantastic
um
and then here i'm saying using redis
node redis is client
it's got a dot graph dot query
and that's a command in redis it's a
graph.query i pass in the key that
contains my graph
called mine dungeon because
imagination
and then i pass a query just like i was
showing you earlier the same queries so
i'm matching a room
where uh the room id it's a different
syntax here we're saying id of room
you can id is a function you pass it a
node it will give you the id of it or
you pass it a relationship it'll give
you the idea of it where that equals one
so this will return room number one
and then it gets returns the name
and uh the id
and so if i run this little bit of code
npm run demo
we can see that i get back headers of
name and id which is what i set up here
uh the room number one is the red jail
although as an american that doesn't
feel like how jail should be spelled
and there's the id of one
and then we can see that it returned a
response in
a quarter of a millisecond
which is kind of cool
i mean it's local i mean it's going to
be fast right
and so we could put any query we want in
here like we could say
uh match let's do match
let's do sort of the match start the
star.star match n
just get rid of the where
and we'll just return
and i'm not sure what this is going to
do actually i mean i know what this does
but i'm not sure i haven't tested this
variation
with this sample code before
there we go
oh look it's a raise
[Laughter]
i'm sure there's data in there somewhere
so
yeah that was that was delightful little
response wasn't it it's like that it's
like that no no no no no no batman video
that was on the internet it was real
popular for a while
because javascript well let's let's go
ahead and do this query somewhere that
it might look a little nicer and so i'm
going to use redis insight and i'm this
is redis insight one reddish insight two
is out but they haven't added the it's
still a preview and they haven't added
the cool graph features that are in site
one yet to it yet
so i'm gonna do match
and return
and here
is that font big enough by the way
it should be reasonably big
and i'm just going to go ahead and full
screen this so this is giving me the
entire graph and it actually showing me
the relationships as well this this just
looks cool right because i can like grab
these nodes and drag them around and
it's just kind of a fun little demo but
i can double click on these
you see that here's all the randomly
generated rooms this is the name of my
dungeon here
let's see if i can scroll down and see
it
or zoom in and see it
the deep castle of
sardana lux
i don't i've got a random fantasy name
generator here and so it generates some
really weird stuff
um
let's let's run it again and see if we
get a different
dungeon
and we'll just refresh this query
and now
we zoom in
this is hard to do on the touch pad
it's the
the dim caverd caverns of glasmuzz
it's always kind of fun the random names
that this thing comes up with
and um if we if we do like a more basic
query let me
um
let's see match
uh d dungeon
my sample graph does not exactly match
up to the
the the ones in the slide i actually
created a dungeon node and it has
entrances eggs and systems to rooms but
if we match all the nodes of type
dungeon which there will be only one and
return it
then
we just get that one node
and that's the dim cap dim caverns but
if i double click on this
there's the rooms
there's the black chamber the painted
pit the vile stairs
the vile stairs contains a lot of
treasure oh no no it's it's not treasure
it's monsters it contains a lot of
monsters
including
fair andrea the displacer beast
two knolls and
pannezia something the giant ant i guess
that's probably the displacer b's pet i
don't know
and i could go to the black pit
and then it shows me more relationships
and i can kind of walk around for this
tool which is
it's actually kind of cool right
it makes it really visual i mean
obviously visual isn't useful for coding
it's good for visualization it's kind of
in the name
but if we wanted to look at the actual
data that i got back from this dungeon
query you can click over here and say
here's the the data
so like if i wanted to match all the
rooms
let's uh
let's say match
r colon room
return r
enter
that's just going to give me all the
rooms but if i go to the tabular view
then here's all the rooms and their
names
actually it's paginated so there's the
rest of them so you know we can get like
meaningful results out of this for you
for like actual work right
so but yeah so that's my little demo
there uh this code's all in github of
course so feel free to play with it
um i do love seeing look at that
half a millisecond
so
yeah i think that's all i got in the
demo here
yeah let's get the slides back up here
i got 10 minutes we'll have time for
questions don't worry
uh i've talked about some of the
practical applications obviously
dungeons and dragons is not a practical
application for graph databases
and unless you're hasbro than i suppose
it is
wizards of coast may actually maybe
they're using this for dnd beyond i
don't know
but social networks are sort of like the
canonical example because a social graph
is very
tied to this sort of model
i mentioned genealogy as well it's sort
of a social graph over time with people
you may or may not like
um
transportation networks i mentioned
those as well
um you know you could do these path
inquiries and find like
the best path based on traffic
conditions even
and uh the one this kind i didn't
mention that's kind of neat is logistics
so if you're trying to figure out where
the e coli tainted spinach came from
because that's a problem
um
and you've got a graph that represents
all the farms all the trucks all the
warehouses
all the
all the stores
and you're like well people who got sick
bought it at this store you could do a
graph query and find all the farms that
spinach could have came from
and and of course there's the most
obvious one which no one wants to talk
about which is contact tracing
that's a totally i mean it's actually
really simple problem solved with graph
because it's got
it's got two types it's got a node which
is people
and it's got a relationship which was
we're in the same place
and that's it right
and so uh that's another good graph
application
hopefully we don't have to use it as
much as we we did
so lots of practical applications i
actually think that if you're uh if
you've got a properly scoped app graph
is not a bad candidate for a lot of
things things you wouldn't necessarily
think would be obvious the more mundane
things you were like i'm just going to
put this in a relational database like
you could use a graph database to do
that
because it does map neatly to your
problem domain
i've been noodling on doing a talk i was
going to call like graph graph and graph
attorneys at law
and the idea was i was going to use a
graph database to store my database to
store my data and then it's going to
have an object graph of my objects in
memory
and then i was going to expose that
using graphql
but i suspect that i just wouldn't need
the layer in the middle
and then i could probably just build an
adapter on top of redis graph that
exposes a graphql result
but i haven't done the experiment so
we'll see
here's some resources for you to go
check out
you can tell i edited my slides this
morning to make them better because
there's a weird gap between redis and
redis stack
but there's if you want to learn more
about uh redis in general you can go to
redis.io if you want to learn about
redis stack which is redis with a bunch
of modules that's also out on redis.io
at docslash stack
you can install it as a docker image
like i did you can do it in the cloud
you can do it all the ways that you
would want to do it there's even a brew
install
redisgraph.io if you want to find out
the details on
the cipherquery language and what parts
redis graphs specifically supports
um there's the spec out there from neo4j
for the cypher query language and the
open cipher spec
and then here's a link to a blog post
that i wrote
a couple years ago which is sort of the
inspiration for this talk
you do not have to worry about capturing
this because i have conveniently given
you a qr code that you can scan
this qr code is totally reliable it will
never give you up
nor will let you down
it actually does take you to the repo i
want to rick roll you so badly but i
just can't good faith do it
and um i've been working for redis for
uh uh die four minus one years so please
go check out some of our stuff we've got
a discord server uh which i'm always on
except when i'm at ndc and then i'm
never on there
uh we got free classes at redis
university
and uh you can set up a cloud version of
reddit stack or just redis redis out at
credits.com try free
that's what i've got um
thanks a lot i've got time for we've got
about five minutes for questions i think
uh the yes relation of two relationships
of the same type between the same as you
know so we're made if you're in vegan
it's 40 meters away we may be
distributed
i don't think so because um the way the
graph store so the question was is can
you create the same relationship with
the same type
uh but with different data
so can i have a
like i follow you
and then
maybe there's some other number
associated with that and then i follow
you again and some other number right
i'm not positive
uh with restraint specifically i don't
think so though because the way it's
stored internally
um
is with a sparse matrix
and so so
one way to model a graph i don't have
any slides on how these work internally
but there's two ways to model graphs
internally one is you can have a bunch
of linked lists and then the linked list
says this
for each node
and it says this node here's all the
nodes it connects to and so you do a lot
of of n operations over those lists to
find things it doesn't scale very well
it's slow
now the other way is you can use a
matrix where you've got all the nodes
and all the nodes and then you get a num
numeric value that says they're related
it's kind of like when you look at like
for in the before times when we used
paper maps
before the iphones came out uh you would
have these little charts in there would
say
distance from like you know bristol to
london
if you're driving and it would you know
give you a number
and then they look like that
and it would be for every node in the
graph and the problem with that is that
space complexity grows quickly
every single time you add a node you're
doubling it
or whatever whatever the math is i think
it's doubling
it's a lot
and um
what
redis graph does is using a sparse
matrix which is
sort of a compressed version of that
matrix and because it's a matrix i don't
think you could put the same type
multiple times because it would they'd
overlap each other
so so i
my money's on it won't work but i
haven't tried it
good question
other questions
over there
yeah
yeah the question is basically can you
put a value on a relationship between
two nodes the answer is yes you can and
you can query on that in the same way
that you query on the nodes i have found
that when i want to put a lot of values
on a relationship
it usually means i want a new node
and so i i'm and
it's just what i've sort of discovered
and playing with with these tools remind
you i haven't built any proper
production code with this i'm i'm a
developer advocate i don't do real work
but um
but what i found is generally like i was
i was doing on stream i was building
what i was calling redis mud and so i
was building this dungeon but i was
going to build a text-based multi-user
dungeon
online and i'm like well we've got rooms
and there's relationships which are the
connections between the rooms and i
quickly realized that i had another node
type which was door
and so
um but yeah you can put those values on
there and you can filter on them
so there are ways to do that so you
could say well
wait this this distance and say well how
much traffic's on this road and then
okay well then that changes which is the
shortest path
because it's not really the shortest
number of hops now it's the
shortest total value
of the
relationships
in that line
great question i saw another question
over there somewhere back there
over there we'll go there
uh the question is can you create the
same reciprocating relationship when you
create a command um
there's
there's one way that i'm positive you
can do it
there are instances where you can use
double-headed arrows
like when you're matching and you say i
don't care what direction the
relationship is it can go either way you
can use a double-headed arrow in a query
i don't think you can do that when
you're creating
but you can create a node with a
relationship give it a variable and then
reference that variable a second time so
if i have like a room and i want to put
a monster if i have a room and i want to
connect it to another room i can say
room one
and then room two could be referenced on
either side of it
so you can do that
right there
so the question is is there any real way
to infer relationships like a bulldog is
an animal and it's also a type of dog
that sort of thing there's
there's sort of two ideas there um one
idea is is this relation nodes can have
multiple
labels
so i could make a node that has a label
of animal a label of dog and a label of
bulldog which actually kind of lends
itself it's reminiscent of object
inheritance hierarchies in
object-oriented programming languages
i think there could be some value in
doing that
probably about as much as there isn't
using inheritance over composition but
but uh the other thing i think this is
more what you might be hitting at is
that graphs are ways of representing
object graphs
like you know so i've got a node that is
an animal i've got a node that is a
dog i have a node that's a bulldog and
then i can create relationships between
them and i put weights on those to say
how tightly related they are
and then you can
do queries on those relationships and
get an idea of how
closely related concepts are or like you
can do it for content recommendation
like you've got well this person's
really into javascript and javascript's
kind of like typescript
he's
lovely sorry
did i offend everyone
but you know if you you know so you
you like this you might like this other
thing
it's kind of it's kind of the same
problem as
recommending friends
because what they're doing is they're
looking at the density of the
relationships between nodes so uh if i'm
connected to you on on facebook
and then you've got a bunch of friends
and i'm connected to most of them but
now all of them you can there's a you
know there's a lot of relationships
there and you can count them and say
well if this is really high then you
probably know this person over here too
so it's a similar sort of problem
so
i think we're out of time for questions
happy to chat out in the lobby
afterwards as well but
thanks a lot everyone you've been a
fantastic audience
and i mean that in a totally pandering
way